I thought it was pretty funny although  Michelle Williams feels venom will  deliver a good laugh  she says her 12 year old daughter  Matilda will not be seeing her mom's new  dark action movie she's not into  anything that's scary so this is this is  not going to be for her yeah I think  that I think that that leg the fangs  would out funny thank you for her that  power it's not completely awful you have  no idea how much you're scaring me right  now the actress also revealed to eat see  who she got advice from ahead of  starring in her first superhero film I  don't have a lot of friends that have  played superheroes so I didn't really  have anybody to reach out to I just kind  of leaned on Hardy on Tom Hardy somebody  in a movie he's pretty sturdy genre I  don't know whatever shoots in New York  City yeah give me at home  [Music]